good close out by cole anthony the
rookie
going up against trey young but trey
burns him this time just a little move
and he could do it with his passing
check this out where's the passing
that really sets him up but this nice
look
and the hawks start the set
[Applause]
trey drills the top side three
foot three pointer by trae young after
the
his wingman herder cleared out from
straight on
nothing but the bottom of the sack solid
first half for trey
what a great addition he and bogdanovich
will be for the hawks trey
dials up a deep three and everybody's
getting involved but it's the ball
movement
willing to swing the ball to the next
guy's trey young knocks down a three
there
and there is kyle anderson missing the
15-footer hawks on the push
deep three from trey is good
[Applause]
[Music]
here's trey and trey steps into that
three
that's a rhythm three for him 218
left second quarter
[Music]
trey with the bomb of a marant
bulls come back to tie it
trey with a deep one good
trae young with six of the hawks 10.
[Applause]
floor spread for the hawks
with a step back and nails it
archer diacono on the island well
archery yakino he was like
would somebody come over give me help
trey up and in trey hits another
three-pointer
my goodness and then you keep going and
then by then i can act like oh and then
i can say the answer but you just
stumped me all the way
and then you called me out trey young
hits his first three of the game
12-10 detroit
trey backs up fires hits the three
timeouts trey working against the rookie
drains this one 23 points on wednesday
hits
six of eight from three-point land trey
a deep three
swish trey young walk right into that
three
long range shooting there's one from the
logo for trey young
happy new year everybody remember kyrie
wednesday night started cold he was
three for 16 through three periods
trey steps on the gas now backs up
shoots over
camaro and drives another one right
through the string
lever's gonna be a key guy for brooklyn
yeah in the absence of
the injured spencer dinwiddie yeah he's
going to be asked to step up big time
nothing but net hawks continue to cook
57-46 but deandre moved it a little bit
too
eight seven calves trey from deep
[Applause]
trey with the bomb and he connects
[Applause]
[Music]
trey launching connecting
trey gets that three to go he said
yesterday wasn't worried
then tree come trey comes off of the
screen kind of a brush screen
no help trey knocks it down
rebound tipped out but trey claims it
trey with a deep three
[Applause]
for trey and five dimes and what the
hawks have to do
here is just keep doing what they're
doing offensively let's keep making it
tough for him
on the defensive end trey with a monster
three good
trey young with 13 his first three of
the night sixth overall pick in the
draft two summers ago out of texas tech
he and hunter of course went head to
head in the national championship game
trey with a deep three i remember that
they were going at it deandre hunter
pick and roll getting to his what we
call the sweet spot for three
puts him up six
as the guys mentioned minnesota playing
without their leading scorer karl
anthony towns as trey hits another big
three
he's got 10. i mean watch him what is he
doing he
is so far away from trey he turns to the
basket
on both of those threes and see him
again here where are you going
so i'm going to say maybe and shot it
too long hit the back of the iron
solomon hill the rebound
trey at midcourt
trey a deep three and a six point lead
that's the dagger that's the dagger
a minute left in overtime 119-113
what a night here what a pass here by
trey but it started with this shot right
here
money we'll save it for one of those
west coast telecast here
trey deep one good
[Applause]
23 in the first half for trey young
trey just walks right nice and easy
and just let it go
hurt her from the wing john
gets it out detroit deep three good
trey young hits the 30-point plateau
with that monster three
well they're not going away the hawks
had their chance to kind of put them
away this quarter collins
reed went down no call trey lets it go
swish
[Applause]
trade keeps the dribble going a little
bit of space is all he needs
and trey young has 36.
inside of the final four minutes of the
third quarter as trey brings it over
step back three he is failing it right
now
hey female 40 for trey
collins back to trey corner three good
he's got 43. another unbelievable
offensive night for trey young he has
had the stroke going
big time
65-64 hawks trey for three that's good
acapella finding galinari passes up a
three
[Applause]
and now young in the corner and that one
rattles home
back-to-back possessions three-pointers
from trae young
still a three possession game hawks
can go into double figures oh how about
it trey young
from long range
ice cold all game long he drills a 32
footer to give the hawks an 11 point
lead
in range in range and yes you
caught it that was deep
and he pointed to the spot 11 point lead
in range
in range and yes you caught it
that was deep
tie game at 65. trey will launch over
kyrie and connect
the three-pointers here in the third
quarter this one
the deep ball and atlanta leading yeah
the mentality should
should be every shot that he takes yes
needs to be a contest
there you go trey gets an open look
career three-pointer he's the tenth
player in hawks history to reach that
total so congratulations detroit yes and
like i said just having history in the
guy who's been through that and you can
see when we asked the questions
which what gave me chills is when we
listen to him
talk and think back to those times
oh and i like this right here i like
trey coming off a screen lizards have
scored 11 consecutive
to kind of make this a ball game here
coming down the stretch
something we really didn't want to see
deep three yes the technical foul was
assessed to rajon rondo
i didn't see him on the bench i figured
and not goody
so goody's still got all his meal money